6 23 here it is Monday morning there is
a new way to detect Als at home and it's
much easier than past message methods
and it's so very important joining us
this morning indu Navarre founder of
everything ALS a nationwide organization
and the Peter Cohen Foundation Andrew
thank you for coming in this morning to
talk about ALS a hideous disease it's
horrible it's touched your life and your
family as well let's just talk about ALS
and how I guess prevalent it is uh in
society right now yeah thank you very
much for having me here
um you know every 90 minutes somebody's
diagnosed with ALS the issue that we
have at the ALS is that it's actually
the prevalence the same as Ms but you
hear about Ms a lot more because people
live longer with alas people have two to
five years from the time you get
symptoms on set to get diagnosed so that
is one of the big problems that we have
is the fatality of the disease it's
horrible horrible disease let's get
right into the the this idea of
detection and a way to sort of get a
head start on treatment and at least
diagnosing it what can people do and
what are some of these new methods that
are that are being Incorporated so
there's a lot of physiological data that
is how you speak and how you move and
how you use your fingers so there are a
lot of signals and so what we're doing
is we're using sensors along with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning to predict what's going to
happen so instead of waiting for it to
happen that's too late by the time you
actually get diagnosed today and and the
the unfortunate thing is there isn't a
cure obviously for ALS we know that
that's an ongoing effort but at least
the earlier you can detect it the more
you can treat it correct correct there
are some treatments today for ALS so
when you do it early it will help and
also it's a chicken on the egg problem
uh you know if we actually had stage
four equivalent of cancer detection and
never know at stage zero and stage one
we wouldn't be where we are today in
neurology that's where we are we're
actually catching everybody at the stage
four equivalent of cancer so if you have
early diagnosis then we can actually
have them participate in the clinical
trials where we would be able to see the
changes uh in the body for these
diagnosed patients with the drug how can
people take part in in this kind of a
study so what we're doing is it's called
citizen driven research that that is we
the people who've been affected by the
disease are taking charge and creating
This research so if people go to
everything als.org research tab that is
all the research that's put together and
we want we want to encourage people to
join in and we want to encourage people
who have ALS also family members or
friends we call them controls even if
they don't have ALS they can actually
participate in our studies the
information is power it's important to
be honest with your own assessment and
really to take part in doing something
here to help with ALS India Navarre
thank you for coming in this morning
it's such an important topic we
appreciate it thank you very much thank
you so much for having me